it's no Hollywood Boulevard no Walk of
Fame instead Kevin Spacey faced a walk
of a different kind through the rain
into a dreary London courtroom to face a
jury
in the stand he was cross-examined on
charges of sexual assault against four
men Each of which he denies
accused of grabbing one man's crotch he
replied I do not accept a single word
that comes out of his mouth asked why
the complainant would be lying Spacey
said money money and then money
it should perhaps come as no surprise
that a Hollywood actor of Kevin Spacey's
stature is able to create drama but
drama there was at times the courtroom
burst into laughter at others the judge
had to intervene as exchanges between Mr
Spacey and the prosecution reached Fever
Pitch
in one such exchange Spacey denied
touching another man he denied it in
colorful terms to much Amusement in the
gallery yes that's exactly where you did
grab him isn't it the prosecutor replied
Spacey looked at the judge and said
really before answering I did not
Mr Spacey was repeatedly asked by the
prosecution whether he used his Fame to
pick up men
I'm sure if I wanted to I could have had
sex all the time but I didn't he said
this lawyer to the Stars told me it was
important that Spacey gave evidence
himself it's always difficult for the
accused whether to take the stand or not
now it was dramatic testimony and we'll
see what effect that that has but he
really needed to come out and explain
these allegations in his own words and
let everyone understand where he was
coming from and all these incidents
otherwise it would be
his word against their word against
silence
for years Kevin Spacey has played to
audiences of millions but now it's an
audience of 12 that counts 12 jurors who
will decide whether he walks away a free
man or in Chains Matthew Thompson Sky
News Southern Crown Court